Let's move on to another trait. Dwarfism. Dwarfism describes
an individual of particularly short stature as a result
of slow or deficient bone growth. Now the most
common type of dwarfism occurs in roughly one out of
10,000 people. Let's take a look at a fictional
family with an African American background. This is Bobby. And
here's a pedigree of Bobby's family with regards to
the trait of dwarfism. Here you see that Bobby is
unaffected by dwarfism. And neither his mom or
his dad or his sister, are affected by dwarfism,
either. However, he has a paternal grandmother. A
paternal uncle. And two first cousins, male and female,
that are affected by the trait of dwarfism.
Before we explore the genetic reason behind this trait.
I want you to first tell me the inheritance
pattern that you see for dwarfism in this pedigree.
Based on the pedigree you see here. And what you've already learned about
inheritance patterns and dominance. I want you to tell me first what you
think the most likely inheritance pattern is for dwarfism. Is it autosomal, sex
linked, or maternal? And tell me the
dominance, does it look dominant or recessive?